ce qui les fait pas je sens le nepad
oui ne fait pas de bruit marchés sera
nul n'est pas ce texte d'henri
meschonnic et la terre cool lance
l'insurrection poétique de
voisins-le-bretonneux à l'origine de
l'idée yves godin poète et deezer est
inhérent d'abord le principe c'est de
donner la parole donné la parole à
celles et à ceux qui ne sont pas
forcément les plus loquaces c'est à dire
montrer que chaque être humain est là
pour grandir pour faire un pas devant
pour et en se libérant de cette façon-là
libère tous les autres qui sont autour
la poésie elle va nous donner des ailes
elle va nous donner de quoi de quoi
encore mieux grandir et puis entente des
belles choses on peut être caressé des
oreilles peut-être bercé ceux qui ont
besoin d'être bercé à un moment donné
voilà les acteurs de cette insurrection
des élèves de primaire de saint quentin
en yvelines dont deux classes vie
sinoise ils ont eux mêmes choisi les
textes ont fait des gestes en même temps
pour ce pur anglais pour se repérer
m'ont poussé et on en a fait en anglais
en argent et je prends me comprend
néo-zélandais sam j'appris
un ou deux mois puis petit à petit on
les savait de mieux en mieux on arrivait
à couper à part les intonations basée
sur l'écouté de l'autre cette
manifestation marque la fin de la
résidence deal gaudin le poète a passé
trois mois sur la commune de voisins